>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ellen Oh: Good morning.
Hi. My name is Ellen Oh.
Thank you.
You're making me blush.
I'm the president of We Need Diverse
Books, and I'm so grateful for all
of you coming in the rain
to be here with us today
at the Second Walter D.
Myers Award Ceremony.
Thank you everybody.
[ Applause ]
So it is so hard to believe that
it's only been less than three years
since We Need Diverse Books
formed, and we have had
so many changes happen, and I'm just
so proud of everybody in this room
that has been a part of that
change and supporting the movement
for better literature
for all of our children.
I couldn't be prouder of all
that WNDB has done, and today,
I'm so excited, I have
the great honor
to introduce the 14th librarian
of congress, Dr. Carla Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Carla Hayden: Well good
morning and welcome to the Library
of Congress, and thank you Ellen.
And you can imagine, you know,
you have many things that you do
at as a librarian of congress.
There aren't many where I
get to bring my favorite book
from childhood and talk about
the need for diverse books.
And so I want to thank you for
sponsoring the Walter award
and the work that you're
doing every day.
As many of you might know, I started
my career as a children's librarian
and one of my colleagues
is here today.
[ Applause ]
It was in the 70s.
I could admit that.
And at that time, working in a small
storefront branch on the south side
of Chicago, there weren't many books
to give the young people
I worked with.
And when I think about that and
what we've been able to accomplish
in a relatively short period of
time and the push to keep it going,
I think about what
Bright April meant for me.
Even though this book, and I don't
remember who put it in my hand,
but somebody saw a little
skinny African-American girl
with two pigtails and said, "Maybe
you'd like to see this book,"
and even today I can't
stop hugging this book
because what happened was I saw,
I thought, she's much prettier,
myself reflected in
something that was important.
Something that reflected my
experience, a loving family,
an opportunity to be a
brownie, all of those things,
and I love this book
so much and checked it
out so much that I got fines.
Full disclosure.
And the fact that books can be
mirrors which is just as important
as well as windows to other people
and other experiences is something
that you celebrate, and I
know that you are working hard
to inspire others to do the same.
I also and thanks to
organizations in just three years,
all you've been able to do, the
publishers continue to be, I think,
cognizant of the importance of
showing all types of characters,
all types of families,
all types of situations.
And the books we're here to
recognize today represent the best
in children's literature, and
congratulations to all of you.
You may also know that
Walter D. Myers was a friend
of the Library of Congress.
He was a frequent participant
in our national book festival
and a beloved national ambassador
for young people's literature.
We can all agree he died too soon.
He still had much work to
do, but his legacy continues
through the Walter Award.
He spends much of his time
when he wasn't writing
inspiring young people everywhere
to read more.
And he knew, as all of us do,
that reading can be the path
to self-enlightenment,
self-enrichment, and understanding.
When he served as the
national ambassador,
he was just continuing what he had
been doing for most of his life,
traveling the country
spreading the word.
So I'm proud that the Library
of Congress is here today
celebrating his legacy.
So now let me hand this
over, and you'll notice
that I'm pretty reluctant because
I just want to also say thank you,
thank you, thank you to all of you.
The winners, the people who selected
you, and the people who are working
to make sure that another child gets
the right book at the right time.
Kathie Weinberg, fellow
librarian and a great supporter
of the Young Reader's Center,
and not to mention the chair
of the Walter Award
will get things started.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathie Weinberg: Thank you
very much, and we all want
to thank Dr. Hayden so much for
her support of the Walter Award
and ceremony, and a big thanks
to the Library of Congress staff.
This is only the second
year of the award
and We Need Diverse
Books has been privileged
to hold the Walter Award
ceremony and reception here
at the Library of Congress
both years.
We are very appreciative
of your hospitality
and certainly the assistance of
Pam Jackson Center for the Book
and Karen Jaffe and the
YRC staff so thank you.
And while I'm giving thanks,
I want to say I am not the
chair of the judge committee.
I am the co-chair.
My fellow co-chair Kerry
Hong is back there.
I want to thank her.
We have bonded at the hip but -
[ Applause ]
And today we have three of our
judges here, Nia Hora Andre,
Derek Ivy, and Shannon Lake.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Unable to attend but with us
in spirit is Karen Lemons.
And we also want to thank the
We Need Diverse Books volunteers
for all their help today.
They're the ones with
rain spots all over them.
They've been going back and forth so
thank you very much for your help.
Our guest speaker and
moderator today is author Rachel
Renee Russell.
She's the author of the
Children's Choice Award
and New York Times best
selling the Dork Diary series.
Rachel, I am sure receives more
fan mail than anyone in this room.
If you're middle school career did
not include being part of the CCP,
cute, cool, and popular you
could have used her books
to navigate your time
in middle school.
In addition to being an
author, Rachel is an attorney
and of course mother of
two wonderful daughters.
Rachel has also been
an amazing supporter
of We Need Diverse
books in our mission.
So it's with pleasure that
I introduce Miss Russell.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russell:
Good morning everyone.
I'm excited to be here.
I just wanted to say a few
words, and I wanted to talk
about why we need diverse
books in 2017.
Many individuals are passionate
about increasing diversity
in children's literature and
those numbers are growing daily.
On March 15th, 2014, the late
celebrated author Walter D. Myers
and his son Christopher Myers,
both wrote out their pieces
for the New York Times
about the lack of diversity
in children's literature mere months
before the hashtag We Need Diverse
Books was created.
The editorial piece was
titled "Where are the People
of Color in Children's Books?"
It helped spark and renewed
the debate and passion
for change that we're seeing today.
Was it [inaudible] who read that
article in the New York Times
and decided to take action?
No. It was mostly young adults,
book bloggers, authors, librarians.
And others.
Many of you here today.
It made me want to change things.
Since then, We Need
Diverse Books has grown
from a simple hashtag
to a powerful movement.
One that is increasing the
number of diverse books
and diverse authors
published in our society.
We must continue to
advocate for change
because the situation is
more urgent than ever.
Recent data from the US Census
Bureau indicates that almost half
of the American children
born under the age
of five years old are
people of color.
We need to make a concerted
effort to ensure that the books
that they will be reading are a
reflection of the world around them.
These books must contain
characters as diverse
as the children reading them.
So, how can we make
change for the better?
There's no easy answer, but I
think the logical first step is
to continue to increase the number
of diverse children's
authors being published.
The end result will be
an increase in the number
of books for diversive children.
I personally know there are authors
out there, manuscripts in hand,
waiting patiently to help
change the landscape.
So who will also benefit from
diverse books in addition
to the children from
diverse backgrounds?
Everyone. In an assembly
of people from all facets
of the publishing industry,
publishing houses, booksellers,
book bloggers, authors,
librarians, et cetera,
as well as the general
public including adults,
teens, and children.
I think everyone will better
relate to books when the authors
and characters reflect them
and or our society at large.
This annual award ceremony
is the perfect time and place
to continue this conversation
and recommit ourselves
to making these changes.
Although I have diverse
characters in my Dork Diary books,
I felt compelled to do even better.
To do more.
To say more because our
children deserve it.
This is both a challenging
and exciting time
for the publishing industry, and I
am confident that we will succeed.
[ Applause ]
Now we can get to the fun part.
I am thrilled to introduce
two talented
and critically acclaimed authors,
Brendan Kiely and Jason Reynolds.
Co-authors.
[ Applause ]
Co-authors of the New York
Times best-selling book,
"All American Boys," and winners
of the Walter D. Myer Award
for Outstanding Children's
Literature in 2016.
Together, Brandon and Jason have
traveled across America visiting
and inspiring youth
one student at a time.
Brandon's first novel, "The Gospel
of Winter" has been published
in an impressive 10 languages
and in 2015 was selected as one
of the American Library
Associations top 10 best fiction
for young adults.
It was also a Kirkus
Review selection for 2014.
Another of his books, "The Last
True Love Story" was published
in September 2016.
Brandon taught high
school English for 10 years
in New York before leaving his
position to write full-time.
He currently resides with his lovely
wife Jesse in Greenwich Village.
Jason is also the award-winning
author of "My Name Is Jason,"
with co-author Jason Griffin.
When I was the greatest,
the boy in the black suit,
as brave as you and ghost.
His forthcoming book,
as if that's not enough,
his forthcoming books are Patina,
Long Way Down, Miles Morales,
a Spiderman Novel, and all
three books are scheduled
for release this fall.
Jason's book "Miles Morales"
will soon be a Spiderman movie
with Sony Pictures.
How cool is that?
I'm sure there will be a
star-studded Hollywood premiere
with paparazzi and a red carpet.
So if you're interested in hitting
up Jason for some premiere passes,
you can get in line behind
me because I'm going.
Jason has received many honors
including the Coretta Scott King
John Steptoe Award for new
talent, NCAAP Image Award
for outstanding literary work,
the Time Book of the Year,
and National Book Award finalist.
Jason currently makes his
home in Washington, D.C. Jason
and Brandon will have the honor
of presenting the 2017
Walter D. Myers Awards to all
of the authors here today,
and I believe they both
have a few words for us.
[ Applause ]
>> Brendan Kiely: All right.
We'll be brief, but I just want
to -- this is a tremendous moment
and it was a tremendous
moment to be here last year
and incredibly grateful and
humble to be here again.
So thank you.
And I just want to say this
because I want to say a few words
about what the Walter
Award means to me.
I stand before you deeply humble and
grateful to be part of the legacy
of the Walter D. Myers Award for
outstanding children's literature.
Walter D. Myers will
forever be remembered
as a literary titan whose
ingenuity, experimentalism,
mastery of narrative voice and
pacing make him a cornerstone
in the institution of
children's literature.
And in addition to
his aesthetic prowess,
I believe his work will
forever be celebrated
for its profound civically
minded and communal impact.
A body of work that shouted
across great distances
to let people know
he cared about them,
that they were not
alone, that they mattered.
His work spoke to so many people
who felt unheard, dismissed,
pushed too far to the
margins of our society.
Here's the problem.
If the majority of
stories published, taught,
and read are about people who
looked like me and experienced life
like me, the underlying message is
that somehow these
stories are more important.
That these lives are
somehow more important.
Walter's books exposed
that lie for what it is.
He wrote an entire cannon of
stories, the manner of stories
that let so many young folks
know their lives matter,
and we need diverse stories,
we need diverse books
because we need records of all
of these lives that matter.
Black lives matter, Muslim lives
matter, refugee lives matter,
immigrants lives matter, gay
lives matter, trans lives matter.
All these lives have stories,
stories to raise up and affirm
that these lives matter,
stories for all of us
to learn from and celebrate.
This is what the Walter
Award means to me.
It's an award that shouts in the
halls of every school, library,
and publishing house in America.
Black stories matter.
Muslim stories matter.
Immigrant stories matter.
Gay stories matter.
Trans-folks stories matter because
they are all American stories.
There is no singular American boy.
There is no singular American story.
There are only the many stories that
gathered together bear witness to
and record and celebrate
the pluralism of our people.
We Need Diverse Books is
the megaphone in the street,
the Walter Award, the call to
action in every library, school,
bookstore, and publishing house.
Do we hear it's call
like we heard the cries
from the tents in the Hoovervilles.
Do we hear it as we heard the chants
and cheers of the suffragettes?
Do we hear it and as we remember
and recognize the songs rising
from the hearts marching
in Selma, Alabama
and years later in
Ferguson, Missouri?
Voices that called to us
to be our better selves.
This I believe.
I hear the Walter's call.
What will be our response?
[ Applause ]
>> Jason Reynolds:
Good morning everybody.
Good to see you.
It's interesting the Walter
will mean something different
to each person who ends it.
It's sort of the beauty
in this award.
Those of us who receive it will
take it from it different things.
For me, I think about
who Walter was.
I think about his story.
I think about the fact
that in Walter's life
and in Walter's career, he
felt like it was James Baldwin
who gave him permission to
be who he was on the page.
He felt like James Baldwin's
voice, his thoughtfulness coupled
with his lack of shame, his
unabashed honesty and authenticity.
It was that, that sort
of bit of fire
on the wall made him feel
relevant, made him feel valuable
and allowed him, gave him
permission to write the stories
that he ended up writing.
Now fast forward 30 years
and you have a Jaclyn Woodson
and you have a Rita Woods Garcia,
and years after that, I'm fortunate,
and I do mean I'm humbly,
humbly fortunate to say
that I could be a part of that
tradition because it was Walter
who made me feel like I had
permission to tell my stories.
To be unashamed.
Unafraid. To be thoughtful
but to not mince words.
To be proud of my language.
To be proud of my culture.
He gave me permission
to do those things.
So the Walter awards to me is all
about tradition, the tradition
or recognition through
permission, right?
It's that -- that's the thing that
I'm always going to hold onto.
And so, for all of us who are
receiving this award today,
it's good to see you by the way.
And for my pal here who has
received this award already
and to the great WNDB for
allowing this to happen.
I have to say that we have
to remember going forward
that our job is to
write books with eyes.
Our job is to write
books that see people.
What we do is not just tell stories.
Not if you're getting this award.
What this award says is that it is
your obligation from here on out
for every single one of your books
to be 300 pages of a permission slip
so that the next person
who reads it --
some other young person
feels emboldened
and empowered despite
their marginalization
of their minority status to
do the same powerful thing
that you all are doing.
That is what Walter
would have wanted.
That is what he did.
That is what we will do and
that is what I charge you all
to do going forward.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Next,
we're going to recognize
the three author recipients
of the prestigious Walter
D. Myer honor books.
And finally, I'll announce
the winner
of the Walter Dean
Myers award for 2017.
The first recognition for honor
book goes to Marina Budhos
for "Watched" published
by Wendy Lamb Books.
[ Applause ]
Marina is the author of such
books as "Ask me no Questions"
"Tell us we're home," and "Remix,
Conversations with
Immigrant Teenagers."
Marina was a Fulbright
scholar in India.
She's currently an
associate professor of English
at William Paterson University.
She lives with her husband and
two sons in Maplewood, New Jersey.
Now, I'm a mom of two children.
She's a mom of two children.
I correctly guessed that Marina
was a very busy mother and wife
from the intriguing
titles of two of her books.
"Ask Me No Questions"
and "Tell Me We're Home."
Would you please come up, Marina?
[ Applause ]
The book "Watched" is about Naeem,
a Bangladeshi immigrant
teen living in Queens.
Past mistakes catch up with him
and the police give him
an offer he cannot refuse.
To inform on his community
or go to jail.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you everyone.
It's such an honor to be here.
First of all, I want to speak
personally about the namesake
of this award Walter D. Myers
because for me this moment has
particular personal resonance.
Several years ago I was sitting at
lunch in the Vermont M.F.A program
with a number of other children
book authors, and Walter was musing
about a book he was contemplating
built around the photographs
of African-American pilots
fighting fascism in Ethiopia.
So, for me, just the
way he was speaking,
somehow a light went off in me.
This became another book
that I've just published
but what's more important, it
was that twinkle in his eye.
His capacity to allow his mind to
roam fused with the sense of justice
of who he was writing about.
In that instance, it was as if the
Walter flame had ignited in me.
I caught a bit of his musing.
So for me to stand here in the
Library of Congress at a moment
when I believe we are living
under an administration
that is anti-knowledge.
It aims to snuff out
that twinkle in our eyes.
That hunger to tell stories that
have not been seen or heard.
We live in a moment of blockade,
of restriction, of walling off.
Banning, suppressing the
glorious and intemperate river
that is human experience.
A book is the opposite.
A novel is the opposite.
There are no walls.
Not in our readers.
Not as authors.
There's only the ceaseless
exploration
of the human experience
in all its diversity.
So I came to write "Watched."
A young Muslim boy's morale
odyssey as he navigates the shoals
of a world saturated and watching,
surveillance, profiling, suspicion.
His very identity is
trapped, walled in, confined.
He's a Bangladeshi
teenager like any teenager.
Mixed up, a screw up, a boy with
a serious case of senioritis.
And yet for him as a young Muslim,
the cost of any misstep is higher.
Somehow, he must find his manhood.
He must find his sense of
agency and morale truth.
That's my task as a novelist
to discover boys like Naeem
as Walter taught us to follow
our instincts as artists.
To never allow our
imaginations to be walled off
and to restore the
dignity, the compassion,
the three dimensionality
of a boy such as Naeem.
Now I'd also like to mention
another interesting resonance.
For me, it's really an honor
to accept this award next
to Representative Lewis.
He was a childhood hero of mine.
I grew up in a very unusual
community in Queens in the 1960s
and 70s, and my childhood bedroom
looked out right across the windows
of Roy Wilkin's with whom
John Lewis battled with
and what marched alongside.
That was my childhood.
And so, for me, that's
who's shaped what I was.
This journey that our country was
becoming, and it's what I care about
and think about in
making these stories.
I'd like to share one other thing.
I was just overseas speaking
to young people in Singapore,
and they had so many
questions for me.
I was talking to them about
what it's like to come
of age in post-911 America.
They said, "Can I come to America?
I've always dreamed of studying in
America," an Indian girl told me,
"But now after three
shootings, I'm afraid."
Another boy asked me, "I was born
in America and plan to go back,
but what will I experience
as a student of color?"
This hit me very hard.
Nearly 60 years ago, my father
came as an immigrant from Guyana.
He'd won a scholarship,
interestingly enough,
to Howard University
a few miles away.
His was an education into many
things including Jim Crowe America.
At the time, because of immigration
laws, he could not become a citizen
but for marrying my American mother.
That means I would not be standing
here in these halls at this moment
in the Library of Congress.
And if it were not for a
black university that reached
out to a young Indian
man across the world.
So what I want to say
to those young people is
that we are fighting
for this in our books.
That we are made of the world.
Not walls.
So I want to thank We Need
Diverse Books for existing,
for creating an award such as this,
but most of all for recognizing
that diversity is actually the very
essence of the human experience.
That when we deny diversity, flatten
it, ban it, refuse to see it,
refuse to get inside the covers
of a book and explore and learn,
we deny who we are as human beings.
I want to also thank Wendy
Lamb, my brilliant editor.
My friend Susan Bartel who told
me to keep writing this book.
My two sons, Sasha and Ralphy,
whose rambunctious, quarrelsome,
joyous existence is somewhere on
the pages of this book, and finally,
I must give all and full credit to
the love of my life, Mark Aaronson.
My husband, my co-conspirator
in all things books.
Many years ago when I was
working at a job I hated,
I sent him a short story which he
promptly read and then called me up.
You can write young
adult he told me.
I guess I can, so I
thank you all again.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russell: Thank you
for those wonderful words, Marina.
Now, the second Walter D. Myers
honorable recognition goes
to Meredith Russo for
"If I Was Your Girl."
[ Applause ]
Published by Flat Iron Books.
Meredith is a resident of Tennessee
and started living as her true self
in late 2013 and never looked back.
Her book, "If I Was Your
Girl" was partially inspired
by her experiences as a trans-woman.
The book is about Amanda, a
trans-gendered teen who moves
to a new school and live every
other student, all she wants is
to make friends and fit in.
She finally finds first love
but is keeping a secret.
[ Applause ]
>> Meredith Russo: Hi.
First of all, I'm overawed by
the legacy of Walter D. Myers,
and I don't think I have words
to really accurately convey
how honored I am to be here.
I'll get the thanks out of the way.
First, I'd like to thank Sara
Barley and everybody at Flat Iron.
I'd like to thank Joe
[inaudible], [inaudible].
I'd like to thank my son
Darwin for being willing
to take some pretty good naps as
I was getting the manuscript done.
And I also wanted to say as a
southerner who cares about issues
of racial justice and civil rights,
enough that I often don't get
invited to Thanksgiving just
because it's a little tedious, I
just want to say that there's nobody
that I would rather lost to than
to Representative John Lewis.
It's truly an honor.
[ Applause ]
You're a hero of mine and just being
in the same room as you means more
to me than I think
you can understand.
So I've prepared some comments.
I will try to keep
it a little short.
So today's an odd day for me.
I turn 30 in a week which is a
birthday I never believed I would
live to see.
When I came into D.C. I landed in
an airport named after a president
who responded to the deaths of
thousands of my brothers and sisters
in the 80s with mostly
indifference and occasional mockery.
It's trans day of visibility today.
Hi. And standing here in
a world where not just me
but trans people all over
this country are stepping
out of the shadows and taking
places in this republic
that have been traditionally
denied to us,
I can't help wondering what the
men who built this city might think
if they were aware that this moment
was coming, if they could see us.
Thomas Jefferson the man whose
books constituted the first attempt
to rebuild this library after the
World of 1812, believed that people
like me deserved to be mutilated.
This isn't even an
indictment of the man.
He owned human beings, and I
won't ever let anyone forget it,
but on the issue of sodomites
he was miles more progressive
than his peers.
The rest of the men who built
this city probably would have just
shrugged and had me put to death.
This is to say well I might not have
known all the historical details,
I grew up with a keen understanding
that America was not for me.
That the American dream
was a lie cooked
up to keep normal people asleep
and people like me hungry.
Sure the time had passed when
I could easily legally killed
for putting on a dress, but the
legal niceties and the realities
which trickle down to my frightened
young mind were vastly different.
Television, books, movies,
religion, most adults,
they all told me the same thing.
Over and over sometimes without
knowing they were saying it.
The American dream is not for you.
The republic is not for you.
Life among us is not for you.
Even if you find people who love
you, your love will drag them
down until you are killed
and you will be killed,
and we will be happy.
And yet, here I am in this city
built by men who have hated me --
who would have hated most of us.
Being honored for a career I
never believed I could have.
I don't think I have the
words to articulate this.
I don't think I even
properly understand it myself.
I wonder what those men would think
if they saw us now here together.
Shall we be kind and
assume their opinions
on [inaudible] issues
of political expedience.
That they might even
be relieved to find
that we have circumnavigated one or
two of the flaws in their legacy,
but probably not and who cares.
The secret of the American dream
is that America itself is a dream.
That America is as much the
faint hope of the slaved,
the desperate yearning of
secret lovers, the quiet courage
of a girl pretending to
be a boy her entire life.
The righteous fury of immigrants
standing together as it is anything.
That there is more of America
in these flashes of light
than there ever was or ever will
be in the atrophy and hearts
of those who seek to harm us.
It is our job as authors and
librarians to kindle that light
in as many minds as we
can, and I stand in awe
of this room's dedication
to the task.
You have all worked so hard, and
I'm so infinitely honored to be here
with you, to be included
in the legacy of a man
as great as Walter D. Myers.
We've already worked so hard
but our work has only begun.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russo: Now the
third Walter D. Myers honor book
recognition goes to Nicola Yoon
for "The Sun is Also a Star"
published by Delacourte Press.
[ Applause ]
Nicole is a number one New
York Times best selling author.
Her book, "The Sun is Also a
Star" was a 2016 National Book
Award finalist.
The book's movie rights
were recently auctioned
by Warner Brothers Pictures.
Her first book, "Everything,
Everything" was also a number
one New York Times best seller.
It will be released as a movie
by Warner Brothers
Pictures on May 19th.
Just a few weeks away.
[ Applause ]
Now some authors have
accomplished a little.
Some authors have accomplished
a lot.
And then there's Nicola Yoon
who has accomplished everything.
Everything.
Just like the title
of her first book.
Two number one New York Time's
best sellers, literary acclaim
and two movie deals all in 20
months, she must be exhausted.
In the book, "The Sun
is Also a Star" Natasha
and her family are
undocumented immigrants
from Jamaica facing deportation.
During her last 12
months in New York City,
she meets Daniel whose Korean
American parents expect him
to attend an Ivy league
school and become a doctor.
Her book is a thought-provoking
story of possibilities, fate,
and the illogical beauty of love.
Now Nicola could not be here
with us today so accepting
on her behalf is Barbara Marcus.
[ Applause ]
Now we have a videotape from Nicola.
So we're going to hear
from Nicola first
and then we will hear from Barbara.
>> Nicole Hume: Thank you
so, so much for naming
"The Sun is Also a Star"
a well to honor book.
It is one of the greatest honors
and highlights of my careers
so thank you so much for that.
I'm going to read a little speech
because I cannot memorize things
so forgive me for not looking
directly at the camera at all times.
I just want to thank a few people.
Wendy [inaudible],
my wonderful editor.
Barbara Marcus, Beverly Horowitz,
John [inaudible], Felicia Frasier,
Dominic Simina, Jillian Vandal,
and everyone at Random
House Children's Books.
Thank you for believing
in me and my career.
Joe Hobeka, [inaudible], Josh Banks.
You guys are the very,
very best in the business.
Thank you so much for
taking a chance on me
and for taking chances with me.
"The Sun is Also a Star" is about
two immigrant kids falling in love.
The book is inspired by my own
love story with my husband.
I'm an immigrant and I'm
originally from Jamaica.
My husband is Korean American, born
in Dallas to immigrant parents.
One of the questions we get a
lot is, "How did you two meet?"
It's asked with the kind of
earnestness that we're both used to.
People ask because I think
our backgrounds make us seem
so unlikely, but the truth is
I have more in common with him
than I've ever had with
anyone in my entire life.
We're not unlikely at all.
One of the themes I
wanted to explore
with this book is all the
invisible threads that bind us.
We are, all of us, shaped by our
own histories, but we're also shaped
by the histories of our families
and friends, or even shaped
by the histories of strangers.
We are not [inaudible].
We are not so different.
Like many people in this room,
I watched the election results
with hope and then
dread and then despair.
The racism, misogyny,
and the xenophobia
that this entire election season
brought to the forum is appalling.
It's a kind of violence.
What is this world we ask?
This is the world we made.
How could this happen we ask?
It happens the way these
things always happen.
We forget as Maya Angelou
said in human family.
We are more alike my
friends than we are unalike.
As you guys know and the world
of children's literature,
there has been a lot of discussion
about the need for diverse books.
Sometimes discussion is productive.
Sometimes it's been painful.
I'm going to be honest
with you and say
that I'm often weary of discussion.
I tire of saying the
completely obvious.
Everyone deserves to see
themselves as a hero of a story.
When you don't see yourself
represented in the media,
you feel erased as
if you don't matter.
When the majority doesn't see
marginalized communities in media,
then it's easier for them to erase
us or to forget our humanity.
We need diverse books
because they breed empathy.
It's hard to hate what
you can understand.
What can we in this
room do to combat hatred
and misogyny, racism, xenophobia?
Write. Write books starring
black girls and boys, brown girls
and boys, Asian girls and
boys, gay and lesbian,
transgender, and [inaudible] people.
When you write these
books, be respectful.
Do not write stereotypes.
Do not harm.
Our job as writers
is to tell the truth.
The truth is we live in a big
beautiful and diverse world.
The truth is the world is
beautiful because of its diversity.
We will not survive if we
do not understand this.
We will not survive if we do not
see each other and love each other.
What do we do now we ask?
To everyone, but especially
to all the beautiful writers
in this room, I say write.
Write like all our lives
depend on it because they do.
Thank you, guys.
[ Applause ]
>> Barbara Marcus: There's
really nothing more to say
than when Nicki speaks she
is always just so on topic,
target, all those things.
So all I want to say is I feel
very lucky to be here today.
And I know that Nicki would have
loved to have been here today
as well but is in the UK
working and promoting her book.
I feel so proud to be in this room
with Ellen and all the publishers
and amazing writers who believe in
and support We Need Diverse
Books and the Walter awards.
I also feel so proud
to be the publisher,
to have been the publisher of Walter
Dean Myers "Flying Lessons" edited
by Ellen Oh, Marina Budhos and Nicki
Yoon and to accept this Walter Award
on behalf of Nicki and
"The Sun is Also a Star."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russo:
Now I am truly honored
to present the Walter
Dean Myers Award for 2017
to Congressman John Lewis,
Andrew Aydin, and Nate Powell
for "March Book Three" published
by Top Shelf Productions.
[ Applause ]
Before Congressman John Lewis
became a respected congressman,
he was clubbed, gassed, arrested
over 40 times and nearly killed
by angry mobs and state police
all while non-violently protesting
racial discrimination.
He marched with Dr. Martin Luther
King Jr. as the youngest leader
of the Civil Rights Movement.
A movement that would change our
nation and our world forever.
Today Congressman Lewis is the
United States Representative
for Georgia's fifth congressional
district serving since 1987.
He is also dean of the Georgia
Congressional Delegation.
Andrew Aydin, an Atlanta native
serves as digital director
and policy advisor to
Congressman Lewis in Washington,
D.C. Andrew took a job with
the congressman after college
and soon learned a fascinating fact.
Listen to this.
It had blew my mind.
As a young man, Congressman
Lewis was inspired
by reading a classic 1958 comic book
about Dr. Martin Luther King called
"Martin Luther King and
the Montgomery Story."
So even back then books
were inspiring young minds
and driving them forward, and I
just thought that was wonderful
that he read a book
about Martin Luther King
and then became who he is today.
Andrew and the congressman
discussed the positive impact
that comic books could
have on young readers.
Then they decided to write
a graphic novel together
about the congressman's experiences
during the Civil Rights era.
Nate Powell has been called the
most prodigiously talented graphic
novelist of his generation
by Book Lists Magazine.
In addition to the March series,
his work includes illustrating many
of Rick Riordan's books
for young people.
His work has received many
honors including the Eisner Award
for best graphic novel.
The book "March Book Three" is the
final volume in the March trilogy.
It is the recipient
of multiple awards
and honors including the
2016 National Book Award.
The series tells the true story
of how a sharecropper's son
helped transform America
from his segregated schoolhouse
to the 1963 march on Washington
to the United States
Congress and beyond.
It is with humble,
awesomeness that I present
to you Congressman John Lewis,
Andrew Aydin, and the illustrator.
Nate Powell.
I got a lot of papers up here.
[ Applause ]
>> John Lewis: Thank you so much
for this unbelievable honor.
The Walter Award.
To be here with Andrew
and Nate, these two guys,
these two young brothers
of mine did the hard work.
They [inaudible] to tell a
story, more than my story
but the story of a Muslim.
It is true that I was born
and grew up in rural Alabama.
Son of sharecroppers, picking
cotton, gathering peanuts,
[inaudible], preaching to chickens.
Sometimes I would be out
and working out in the field
and my mother would have said,
"Boy, you're falling behind.
You need to catch up."
I always said, "This is hard work."
She said, "Hard work
never killed anybody."
I said, "Well, it's
about to kill me."
But in 1955, 15-years-old
and in 10th grade,
[inaudible] I heard Rosa Parks.
I heard the words of Martin
Luther King Jr. on the radio,
and I felt like Dr. King
was speaking directly to me.
He said, "Boy, you
too can do something."
And when I met him in 1958, he
called me the boy from Troy.
I grew up outside of Troy, Alabama.
Attended school in Nashville,
and it was in Nashville
that I really grew up.
Sitting down at lunch counters
and beaten, tear gassed,
going on marches, coming here for
the march on Washington in 1963,
leading a march across that
bridge in Selma, Alabama,
in 1965 for the right to vote.
Both Andrew and Nate have
captured the essence of my life
so I want to thank the two of you.
I'm sorry to get here so late.
I just took a train from New
York, and I have to get up very,
very early to make it,
but I'm happy to see you.
So thank you so much.
Andrew.
[ Applause ]
>> Andrew Aydin: As I see Jason
Brandon and then I look at the three
of us, I can't help but wonder if
once you start doing books together,
you also start dressing alike.
[ Laughter ]
It's just an observation.
I was raised by a single mother and
my father was a Muslim immigrant
who had left when I was very young.
And I started reading comics
after he left because I wanted
to read stories about heroes.
Looking back on it, those stories
tended to be white men in spandex.
I was raised in the
congressman's district.
He's been my congressman
since I was three-years-old,
and as I got to be a
teenager and grew up,
I became very politically conscious
because you sort of can't help
but understand the
injustices in our society
when you see how they
treat a single mother.
When your mother doesn't
want you to grow a beard
or seem anything like
a Muslim person.
Even though I'm not.
I mean I went to Trinity
College in Georgetown
and every Christian institution it
seems like they could put me in.
[ Laughter ]
But when I joined the congressman's
staff and I joined it to help him
with his mail because he gets
a lot of mail, I found a hero
that I wished I'd known as a young
person who wasn't in my books,
who wasn't in my social
studies class.
They didn't teach me
about [inaudible].
They didn't teach about
the [inaudible].
So to have the opportunity
to grow up and work for him
and tell his story and to do
it in a medium that I loved
with all my heart as a child is
the greatest honor I could ask for.
So I'm grateful to all of you in
this room for providing a platform
for stories like this because
one thing I've known --
or come to know over the last
eight years is that there are a lot
of people and a lot of institutions
that don't want to
see these stories.
It's not the money
they want to make.
It's not the stories
they want to tell.
But we can win.
We can make these stories
told through efforts,
through working together,
through dressing alike.
These are teams.
We are teams, and we're fighting
for a world at peace with itself.
So thank you for this honor.
Thank you for honoring "March."
Thank you, John Lewis for
letting us tell your story.
Thank you, Nate.
Your abilities just boggle my mind.
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> Nate Powell: Hey everybody.
Thanks for being here
and for having us here.
Also, I would like to take to
respectfully object that we
in fact have done the
easier share of the work
in bringing the story
of the struggle to life.
And in fact, there is one
person here on this stage
who has done the heavy
lifting and who continues
to do the heavy lifting and
that is you congressman,
but thank you from all of us.
You all, I'd just like
to speak briefly
as a parent and as a cartoonist.
So I'm from Arkansas.
I live in Indiana, and
I have two daughters.
One is two, one is five.
The two-year-old is getting there,
but to speak of the five-year-old,
she's a ravenous reader.
I mean who would have guessed?
Surrounded by books, surrounded by
nerds in the house all the time.
But in our daily reading sessions,
increasingly over these last
five years and increasingly
as she has grown up around the
drawing table and around "March"
in progress and it's reference
to research and documentation,
I'm brought back again and again
to the books that my brother and I,
well really the media
surrounding my brother and I,
including kids TV programs and
everything from the late 60s
into the early 80s, and only
as a parent have I really become
increasingly aware of the subtleties
of what stock photos are chosen for
what elementary school textbooks
and what they show of life in
different parts of America.
Only by moving to the north
and moving to the Midwest
and raising Hoosier kids have I
as a southerner really been able
to confront and process a lot of
the beauty and the specialness
about the American south amidst
the darkness and the ugliness
and been able to recognize
so many more dimensions
of American inequality and American
injustice by living in Indiana
and raising my Hoosier kids with
rapidly expanding world views.
And on that note, I have been -- I
am consistently amazed as a parent
at how fast a young
kid's worldview expands
and how readily they
absorb everything.
And the kinds of inquisitive
questions and the subtleties
of my five-year-old's
questions about the world
around her had made me realize that
I'm consistently lagging behind her.
And so, young people having access
not just to stories and to documents
which reflect their life
and which offer windows
into a much broader world, but
is it too much to ask for media
and for literature that
is simply representative
of the world around us?
And I feel like it actually takes a
lot more effort to work against that
than it does to simply embrace it.
It shouldn't be that hard.
[ Applause ]
However, I'm very encouraged by my
exposure to little kids books moving
into young people's literature.
As a parent, I think this may
actually give me more hope
than anything else in this time.
In recognizing that I am the
one who is struggling to keep up
and to catch up with where my
kids are going to be in the world.
I look forward to the time my wife
and I had discussed this
semi-regularly, for these clues
that at a certain point,
these super cool,
progressive parents are
going to be out of touch.
We're going to be dinosaurs to
some degree, and we're excited
by that prospect, by that
challenge of recognizing
where we're lagging behind
and where we have come
and where we will go as a society.
Also to just speak very
briefly as a cartoonist,
thank you for your embrace of
a comic, and I want to stress -
[ Applause ]
Graphic novels have come a long
way in terms of public embrace
and perceived legitimacy over
these last couple of decades.
I want to stress, it's all comics.
It's okay to say comics.
They're comics and comics have
changed my life time and time again.
Ever since I was three-years-old,
I feel like in a lot
of ways my social consciousness
itself was awakened
by crystal clear running on writing
the X-Men throughout the 70s,
80s, into the early 90s.
Speaking of mirrors and windows
by which to view inequality
and view struggle within
the world we reside,
I thank the X-Men for that.
And also, in terms of comics unique
strengths, in terms of balancing
and communicating equally with words
and pictures, if we're speaking
about representation and
we're speaking about accuracy,
I don't feel like I
always succeeded in the way
that I would have liked to.
That's why we continue making
work, but thank you for the role
that a comic may have played in
literally representing people
at a crucial moment in American
history in a way that has gotten
into the hands of many kids who
otherwise would never have sought
out or had an opportunity
to have exposure
to this literal representation in
a visual form, in a tangible form,
and I think there's
great strength to open.
Thanks a lot you all.
I appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Renee Russo: Just
in closing, I'd personally
like to thank Ellen
Oh for the opportunity
to host this award ceremony today
and meeting Congressman John
Lewis kind of blew my mind.
So I apologize to Nate Powell
for losing it up here in public,
but I had a really
good excuse though.
You guys get to work
with him all the time.
Just see him on CNN mostly.
And I'd like to thank everyone
here for being our special guest.
And in closing, just remember
that We Need Diverse Books
and that this project has
grown from a simple hashtag
to a powerful movement that
is increasing the number
of diverse books and
diverse authors not only
in our nation but the world.
So I'm all done.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.